nous accueillons notre intérieur du
samedi 20 heures ce soir victor lanoux
bon ça
alors victor lanoux
vous étiez l'un des comédiens préférés
des français louis la brocante a fait de
vous une véritable star populaire mais
en 2011 alors que vous êtes en pleine
gloire vous envisagez de mettre fin à
vos jours pourquoi comment votre
histoire vous la raconter dans un livre
intitulé deux heures à tuer au bord de
la piscine publié au cherche midi et à
20h dans salut les terriens
m
mi-temps la neuro bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
or vous êtes né à paris le 18 juin
1936 sous le nom de victor nataf votre
père richard nataf juif tunisien
originaire de sfax passe ses journées à
jouer aux courses à auteuil et à
longchamp vous le voyez pas beaucoup à
la maison non pas du tout alors votre
mère catholique normande est fatigué des
dettes de son mari disparaît assez vite
du paysage familial elle part en suisse
en disant qu'elle a une tuberculose
tue père avait vraiment dans un nul mais
quand elle est revenue et le divorce
quand elle est revenue elle a perdu un
oeil 1 et par contre est revenue et
qu'un mec vrai gars là vous vivez vous
en tête à tête avec ce père l'ombrageux
qui vous met des baffes il est dû à
votre père c'est les basques étaient
dures ouais il avait un autre truc c'est
que quand tu voulais vraiment me punir
il me mettait sur le lit et me taper
avec un élément chabal est sous la
plante des pieds c'est tordu quand même
non alors arrive la guerre et la traque
des juifs ou finirait par être envoyé
dans un petit village de la creuse pour
vous cacher je les fermiers un jour les
allemands débarquent et ils vous
demandent de baisser votre pantalon et
heureusement votre mère avait refusé de
vous faire circoncire riz coup de bol
les allemands s'en vont vous rester là
vous vivrez dans la creuse jusqu'à l'âge
de 11 ans 47 donc et vous remontez à
paris vivre votre adolescence entre les
gifles de votre père l'absence de votre
mère et l'école
un souvenir très précis mais en tout cas
ce qu'assure je n'ai aucun bon souvenir
alors avait pas qu'en fait vous passez
votre vie avec une bande de potes au
métro marcel sembat à boulogne il ya un
mec qui est parti chez les parts il est
parti en indochine il est mort à dien
bien phu et là vous dites moi aussi je
vais être parra
en fait on l'admirait quoi ouais c'était
notre patte il était venu une fois en
termes où il sortait on aller avec lui
dans les gares que ça c'était un nous
avons été fiers de cet uniforme donc là
vous voulez vous engager dans l'armée
pour devenir parachutiste et avant de
partir vous trouver un petit boulot aux
studios de boulogne un boulot de
machiniste un jour il ya le tournage de
notre dame de paris avec anthony quinn
dans le rôle de quasimodo et là vous dit
[ __ ] ça que je veux faire ah bah oui
je te mets qui rentrait son plateau
volumes et à une bonne stand où il est
nouveau en comme ça il avait une bagnole
ou du polonais 11 bourbon banide était
si on fait un truc là je peux me faire
chier toute ma vie sur une échelle donc
j'ai décidé de faire comme lui hélas au
moment où fait cette découverte est
appelé en algérie vous gardez des images
assez atroce de l'algérie il ya un vieil
arabe qui passe sur un âne comme on
imagine quoi et là le supérieur le gradé
vous dit vas-y des comme le melon
vous l'avez pas fait j'aime traîner jeu
les chercher vos fusils spécial parce
que j'ai été tireur d'élite fonnière
je n'ai cherché mon fusil spéciale et
puis je trouvais pas pourquoi je
trouvais pas sur saône elle était devant
mes yeux puis quand je suis arrivé là il
était tout proche de passer dans un
petit bonheur si bien que
parfait pour moi ce qu'il fait victor
que vous passez la guerre d'algérie sans
jamais tué personne en fait annoncé en
juin et tuent personne alors de retour à
paris vous prenez des cours d'art
dramatique et votre prof marcel
tassencourt vous intègre dans la troupe
pour jouer des classiques et c'est la
coordination de 61 vous rencontrer
pierre richard vous faites ensemble un
numéro dans des cabarets comme c'était
le cas à l'époque il y avait il ya des
philippe noiret avec jean pierre darasse
musée d'arras et noir est il y avait là
nous et richard poiret et serrault c'est
une grande époque et francis blanche
chez francis menti qu'un jour est entré
dans un lieu de la main caméra une
vocation qui s'appelait de la galerie 5
en italie et qui vient bien tout comme
sa il qui vous fait quand même vous deux
pieds très bien quelle époque quel est
votre premier film c'est en 1965 que la
vieille dame indigne là vous devenez une
vedette ensuite il ya la sphère dominici
deux hommes dans la ville cousins
cousines adieu poulet une femme à sa
fenêtre un éléphant ça trompe énormément
nous irons tous au paradis
enfin des trucs énormes et en 1975 il ya
un film particulièrement intéressant qui
s'appelle dupont lajoie où vous jouez un
ancien para qui lynchent en arabe et là
vous vous servez pour créer le
personnage de votre expérience de soldat
en algérie évidemment ma culture notre
culture et puis vous devenez louis la
brocante 44 films entre 1998 et 2000 14
6 millions de téléspectateurs en moyenne
un succès absolument hallucinant jusqu
au jour en 2007 où fait un examen de
santé un examen de routine
le médecin à la radio trouve un petit
point vous dites c'est quand même bien
que tu fasses un scanner vous avez un
anévrisme sur l'aorte
si vous faites pas opérer positifs
donnés pour deux ans alors qu'est ce que
c'est un anévrisme sur l'aorte voyez un
pneu de vélo ça arrive quelques fois que
quand on tombe on fait la chambre à air
une petite discret parce que c'est plus
fragiles à s'embrouiller est donc sacré
voilà l anévrisme amusé de la chambre
ailleurs et moi j'avais ça sur l'or qui
c'est vrai que ça a explosé et voilà
donc il est prévu que vous soyez opéré
début 2008 mais en octobre 2007 sur un
tournage vous fait un avc est opéré
d'urgence à votre réveil vous est
paraplégique qu'est ce qui s'est passé
pendant l'opération alors évidemment la
cure gyan il a dit l'opération s'est
très bien passée tu es content on à part
que ajoutent ils effectivement parce que
je sois plus est il avait en même temps
qu'il n'avait donc c'est que des mines
les cordes vocales ils avaient
sélectionné une petite artère médullaire
est-ce qu'il s'en est aperçu
en tout cas il affirme sa gueule mais
moi ça me prouve qu'elle sait de
rappeler j'ai heureusement et véronique
est la seule à croire que vous allez
vous en sortir
véronique toute ma femme elle disait ça
bougera et l'alpr son regard sur mon
doigt de pied elle dit d'ailleurs son
push bouge mais ils l'ont traité de
cannes
et toubib ils ont traité de canon ils
ont dit non non mais non c'est un
réflexe arrive ça mais ça se remettra
pas
jusqu'au jour quelque chose
effectivement fini par se débloquer mais
la remontée sera longue
boosté par l'amour de véronique votre
ténacité et finit par payer en 2009
reprenait les tournages de louis la
brocante
hélas le chirurgien a fait un tel
mauvais boulot que lors d'un ce call on
découvre qu'il faut réopéré
lacets 13h sur le bia cette fois ci
retour à la case rééducation retour au
calme r
et là on vous annonce une troisième
opération là vous refusez et à ce moment
là
il ya une petite voix intérieure de vous
qui vous souffle il est temps d'en finir
pour de bon et un matin où véronique est
partie promener le chien vous prenez
votre fusil vous vous dirigez vers la
piscine vous marcher lentement les du
mal à franchir les 30 mètres qui
séparent votre terrasse de la piscine là
à ce moment là victor vous êtes
réellement décidé à vous tirer une balle
dans la tête
oui celui là sur fond au fond du trou
scheidegger pas tout déboulant fantôme
n'est tombé qu'en île et moi ne sont pas
fantôme en tout cas
ça faisait un moment j'y pensais mais là
ce journal décide ce jour là vous dites
je vais y aller il vous faut une heure
pour arriver près de la piscine vous
vous glisser dans l'eau près prêt à
mourir et là vous vous rendez compte que
vous avez oublié le fusil
sa demande il a un moment donné de mes
arrêts puisque je m'arrête à dormir en
fauteuil qui sera pour me reposer et mon
physique je me posais tout le temps 1 et
pourquoi je suis parti sans de fusil
voilà encore une fois un geste un
miracle un miracle un miracle hélas ce
qui est extraordinaire c'est que donc
vous êtes là dans la piscine comme un
con sen le fusil 1 et la véronique
arrive de promener le chien elle fait ça
va mon amour on déjeune dans 20 minutes
donc évidemment à ce moment là qu'est ce
tu fais tu dis oui j'arrive et vous êtes
celui-ci les ratés temps réel voilà tant
mieux pour nous tony bramwell tant mieux
je suis là aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
alors aujourd'hui à 60 18 ans vous êtes
le héros des enquêtes du commissaire
laviolette tout va bien ça le problème
c'est qu un
risque qu'on a remarqué au dessus des
les deux anévrismes la verrue intérêt
est de lotina
ça fait pas mal hein ça grossit et un
jour ça va exploser donc
je me dis bah c'est comme ça c'est la
vie il est temps que
60 79 aux frais store d'apple
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu